جانبه قال المتحدث باسم الرئاسه التركيه
ابراهيم قال للجزيره ان كل مواقع
التنظيمات الكرديه في الشمال السوري اهداف
مشروعات للقوات التركيه سواء كانت قرب
الحدود مع تركيا او بعيده عنها
فراس همم بالنسبه لنا جميع المؤسسات
والمواقع والنقاط العسكريه والعناصر
التابعه لحزب العمال لكردستاني والاتحاد
الديمقراطي ووحدات حمايه الشعب الكوريه
اهداف المشروعه سواء كانت في غرب سوريا او
في شرقها او في شمالها وسواء كانت قرب
الحدود او بعيده عنها تعتبر كلها اهدافا
لانها منظمات ارهابيه ونحن نلاحقهم حمايه
لحدودنا
واضاف قال للجزيره ان التنظيمات الكرديه
تستخدم تحالفها مع الولايات المتحده
لاطفاء شرعيه على وجودها في جمال سوريا
ترى عناصر حزب العمال الكردستاني ووحدات
حمايه الشعب الكرديه يرفعون العلم
الامريكي احيانا والعلم السوري في احيانا
اخرى لحمايه انفسهم يقولون لن تستطيعوا
مهاجمتنا بان هناك قوات امريكيه او قوات
النظام السوري المكان
الشرعيه على وجودهم في شمال سوريا